[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله علماء على ابواب
المواقف الرسميه لدول قرر قادتها حصار قطر
في شهر رمضان المبارك لم يترددوا في اصدار
الفتاوى واعلان المواقف التي تبرر الحصار
وادواته فتراها ايه للحكمه ودليلا على
الرشاد وسواء السبيل وسواء تم ذلك خوفا من
بطش الحاكم او طمعا في عطاياه فان المؤكد
ان تلك المواقف المثيره للجدل اعادت الى
الواجهه مجددا النقاش حول خطاب المؤسسات
والشخصيات الدين وادوارها في مثل هذه
المنعطفات ان القدس
الشريف
يناديكم ويستغيث بكم ايها
الاخوه
لتنقذه من محنته ذلك فيصل الفيصل ثم خلف
من بعده زمان لو قال فيه الذي قال لكان من
المحرضين على الارهاب لاستحق ان كان ملك
ان يحاصر وان كان مواطنا ان يلزم الصمت
مكرها لان التفكير ضار بالصحه التفكير
يقود الى الكلام والكلام صنو الحريه
الكلام فتنه هكذا راته الدول الخليجيه
الثلاث وهي تحجر على مواطنيها الجهر
بارائهم ضد حصار قطر لقد حيل في السعوديه
بين المواطنين وبين التعبير عن المشاعر
الانسانيه السويه في انكار حصار قطر
وتجويع اهلها والحاق الضر باقتصادها مواطن
الدول الثلاث محرومون من انكار ما انكره
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي الذي ذكر الدول
الثلاث والتابعه بقيم التراحم بين
المسلمين في رمضان يوشك ان يقول ام على
قلوب
اقفالها وكانت الامارات قد حذرت وتوعدت
شديد الوعيد بالسجن والغرامات الثقال كل
من يبدي بادله تعاطف مع قطر او شبهه رفض
لحصارها البحرين اعتقلت محاميا بجرم رفض
الحصار بعد ان رات في الرجل فيضا من
انسانيه هذا حصار لا قيم فيه ولا نبل كما
يقول معارضه غير ان السواد الاعظم من
الناس دائما معذور ان هو صمت طلبا للسلامه
لكن ما عذر اهل الراي من شيوخ الدين ومن
النخب التي اثرت الصمت في موضع الكلام هذا
واحد من الدعاه ورطه التقويم فوافى حديثه
عن حصار كفار قريش شعب بني هاشم يتقدمه
الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم ومن امن به ومن
كفر من ابناء عمومته واف حديثه ذلك حصار
قطر فهجم لمجرد الحديث عن حصار قديم وعن
معسكرين تمايزا عقيده واخلاقا ولم يجد
الداعيه عمر خالد بدا من التنكر لعبره
التاريخ فقال انه ضد كل من يمس امن مصر
سواء كان قطر او غيرها نجم من الدعاه اخر
هو محمد العريفي وجد نفسه مغردا منحازا
الى قرارات السعوديه لان فيها الحرمين
وهذا احتجاج بما لا خلاف عليه وانصراف في
الوقت نفسه ما يليق بالعالم من بيان الحكم
على الحصار والعريف له سوابق في الاتيان
بالقول وضده هذا حديثه وهو نزيل ليبيا
القذافي اختم هذه الكلمه ايضا بالدعاء
لقائد هذا البلد جزاه الله خير الذي يحرص
على تشجيع مثل هذه المسابقات وعلى تشجيع
حفظه القران ثم لما انهى الثوار حكم
القذافي تبين العريف الحق الابلج فعلت
نبرته كما لم تعلو من قبل بعضهم يقف في
الشارع يسال الناس يشحد في بلد يجري النفط
انهارا تحت ارجلهم الحاكم الذي يربي شعبه
احرارا ليسوا عبيدا بعض الحكام اليوم مع
الاسف يريد ان يكون الشعب مجموعه من
العبيد مجموعه من القطعان مجموعه غلم ربما
كان هذا هو العريف الحقيقي وقد تحرر من كل
سلطان لقد صارت دول الخليج الثلاث ومن لف
لفها من التابعه تحت حصار تتعدد دوائره
فالحصان خاسر بحساب الجغرافيا والسياسه
لانه ينقض بنيه المجتمع الخليجي ويخل خها
فيضعف وهو خاسر بقيم الدين والانسانيه لما
فيه من لؤم الجوار لكن هيئه كبار العلماء
في السعوديه تعمى عن كل ذلك
فتؤدى للقطريين وهو تخريج لا يعرف منطقه
غير ال الشيخ نفسه اما الازهر فهو تابع
التابعين يدور موقفه مع السلطه المصريه هي
بوصلته للحق وهناك خسران اشد وطاه على
الدول الخليجيه الثلاث امام شعوبها وهو
انها اصبحت في صف واحد مع اسرائيل فهي
تحاصر قطر لانها تدعم حماس واسرائيل تفعل
الشيء نفسه ضد قطاع غزه بسبب حماس التفحيط
او التعيسه لمن اراد الدقه في التفريق بين
ضروب العبث لم تحسن قراءه الواقع بل هي
عميت عنه فالاخوان المسلمون احسنوا او لم
يحسنوا هم حكام تركيا والسودان وشركاء في
حكم تونس والمغرب وفاعلون في كثير من
البلاد العربيه من يدل المحاصرين على باب
الخروج فقد اصبح المحاصر
محاصره نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيفين من
تونس الدكتور احميده النيفر استاذ الفكر
الاسلامي وعبر الهاتف من اوكسفورد الدكتور
بشير نافع المؤرخ المتخصص في في تاريخ
الشرق الاوسط نرحب بضيفي الكريمين دكتور
بشير نافع بدايه كيف تقيم انت موقف
المؤسسات الدينيه في هذه الازمه الخارجيه
خاصه
المؤسسات مؤسسات الدول المقاطعه والمحاصر
لقطر سلام الله عليكم عبد الصمد وعليكم
السلام ورحمه على الاخوه المستمعين جميعا
عبد الصمد اولا انا اريد ان اوضح مساله
ربما هي محل اشتباه في الخطاب والثقافه
العربيه
المعاصره في الاسلام السني ليس هناك مؤسسه
دينيه هذه الهيئات مشيخه الازهر مثلا ولدت
في القرن الثام عشر وفقط في القرن التاسع
عشر اصبح لها هذه الاهميه نظرا لل للتنافس
بين محاولات
الخديويه المصريه لاستقلال عن عن اسطنبول
هيئه كبار العلماء في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه اسسها الملك فيصل في في في قبل
وفاته بسنوات قليله اظن في ان لم اكن
انتهت في
1971 وكذلك مناصب الافتاء يعني الملك فيصل
مثلا الغى منصب المفتي الذي كان قد وضعه
والده مؤسس الدوله الملك عبد العزيز الغاه
واقام
في مكانه وزاره العدل ولم يعد منصب المفتي
له هذه الاهميه الا في التسعينات عندما
عندما
اعاد المنصب الملك فهد وا اعطاه للشيخ
المرحوم الشيخ عبد العزيز بن باز ف هذه
هذه مؤسسات هذه مؤسسات صنعتها الدوله
الحديثه الدوله المركزيه للتحكم في في
طبقه العلماء حتى تكون هناك قناه
واضحه لسيطره الدوله على على العلماء
المسلمين السنه ليس لهذه المؤسسات لا
قداسه في التجربه والتاريخيه
السنيه ليس لها هذه هذا هذا الوضع المرجعي
الذي اعطي لها او يحاول البعض ان يعطيه
لها في في من فتره الى اخرى
وحقيقه الامر انه هذه المؤسسات بصوره او
باخرى اصبحت اداه في يد الدوله يعني جهاز
من اجهزه
الدوله تستخدمه الدوله لتسويق قذارتها او
لربما اعطائه بعدا دينيا وشرعيا
وشعبيا تماما الدوله تستخدم هذه المؤسسات
لتسويغ قراراتها لاعطاء قراراتها هذهه ال
الشرعيه الشرعيه الاسلاميه نتيجه لانه
الدوله تعرف ان اغلب الشعوب هذه شعوب
مسلمه وان هذه الشعوب
تقدر العلماء و وان
وان الشعوب للاسلام يعلو على كل ولا اخر ف
وضعت اصبحت هذه المؤسسات بصوره او باخرى
يعني لا اريد ان استخدم كلمه العوبه ولكن
اصبحت هذه المؤسسات بصوره او او باخرى
اداه من ادوات الدوله
ادوات من ادوات تسويغ سياسات الدوله دكتور
حميده النفر الا يقودنا هذا الحديث بناء
على ما قاله الدكتور بشير نافع الحديث عن
العلاقه بين الديني والسياسي هنا بين
الحاكم
والعالم مساء الخير سلام عليكم وعليكم
وبركاته العلاقه بين الحاكم
والعالم علاقه قديمه في العالم
الاسلامي الفتره الحديثه التي تهمنا بدرجه
اساسيه هذه العلاقه تاكد من خلالها الحكام
في العالم العربي خاصه ان تحييد المساله
الدينيه امر متعذر كما حصل في جهات اخرى
من العالم على سبيل المثال في اوروبا على
سبيل التقدير ما حصل بعد عصر الانوار وقع
تحييد المساله الدينيه بصوره كبيره جدا
هذا الامر تعذر تحقيقه في العالم العربي
والاسلامي
ولذلك كانت الفكره التي تراود الحكام في
الغالب هو كيفيه توظيف هذا المجال المجال
الديني سواء سميناها مؤسسه او مرجعيه او
مجال او ما شابه ذلك من التسميات طالما لا
يمكن تحييد الشان الديني وطالما لا يمكن
جعل المساله الدينيه بعيده عن القضايا
الاجتماعيه وقضايا النفسيه وقضيا السياسيه
والتنمويه ومشاكل ذلك فاصبح من المتاكد
لدى هذه السلط الحاكمه في العالم العربي
في الفتره الحديثه والمعاصره اصبح من
المتاكد جعل هذه الاطراف موظفه او مبعده
تماما عن مجال التاثير الفكري والثقافي
والاجتماعي
والسياسي طيب في هذه الحاله وهذا ما
نلاحظه يعني نحن نعيش مرح يعني في هذه
الحاله دكتور حتى ندخل في صب الموضوع
دقائق قليله تفص عن نهايه هذا الوقت
المخصص لهذا الملف يعني حينما يحرم
الاسلام مقاطعه الاشقاء ويدعو دائما لحوار
بين الاخوه واين اختلفت ارائهم او ايا
كانت خلافاتهم كيف نفهم موقف رموز دينيه
على قدر كبير من العلم على قدر كبير من من
الاطلاع المعرفي الواسع بمقاصد الشريعه
ومع ذلك يفتون او يدلون برايهم بان الحصار
او المقاطعه تفيد هذا الشعب مثلا كيف نفهم
هذا الامر وهذا تجاهل نصوص
الشرعيه وفي الحقيقه يمكن ان نجيب عن هذا
السؤال بان ان هذه الاطراف التي تقدم
فتاوى احيانا فيها كثير من التناقض وفيها
كثير من الاسفاف والتهافت هذا نتيجه
اقتناع اطراف كثيره من هؤلاء العلماء
بان خشبه النجاه المتوفره لديهم الوحيده
هي ارضاء من من بيدهم السلطه
السياسيه لانه لم يبق يعني يشعرون بانه لم
يبقى لديهم تاثير حقيقي في المجتمعات لم
يبقى لهم مرج لم تبقى لهم مرجعيه علميه
حقيقيه اجتهاديه كما ينبغي ان يكون له
شانها ولذلك ملزمون نوعا ما بان يستنجد
بالسه الحاكمه للحفاظ على وضعيتهم للحفاظ
على سلامتهم للحفاظ على امتيازاتهم والا
فانهم سيدخلون في صدام غير محسوب العواقب
وهذا ما يخشونه باستمرار طيب دكتور بشير
نافع هناك يعني حتى نرى ايضا المساله
بوجهها الاخر يعني هناك من يتحدث عن
السياسه العصا والجزره في تعامل تعامل
الاجهزه اجهزه الدوله او الدوله مع
المؤسسات الدينيه ورموزها و حتى ان البعض
يؤكد مثلا وجود ضغوط على شخصيات دينيه
لتتخذ بخصوص الازمه الحاليه الخليجيه
مواقف معاديه لقطر وتؤيد الحصار كيف ترى
انت ذلك وهل ترى ان تلك الشخصيات فعلا
معذوره ام انها تتحمل بحكم موقعها الديني
الروحي مسؤوليه امام الله سبحانه وتعالى
وايض مسؤول اخلاقيه امام
الناس معذور او لا ليس هذا يعني ليس
هذا من مهمتي في الحكم ولكن انا يعني
متيقن من انه عدد كبير من العلماء دول دول
الحصار تعرض ل لضغوط هائله
و كما هو
معروف المجال المتاح امام امام طبخه
العلماء المجتمعات الحديثه هو مجال ضيق ام
لم يعد العلماء يعني لم يعدوا مدرسين ولا
قضاه لم يعد لهم اوقاف يعد لديهم استقلال
عن عن السلطات عن الدوله عن مؤسسه الدوله
بمعنى غير مستقلين ماليا غير مستقلين
ماليا غير مستقلين ثقافيا الدوله الدوله
تتحكم في في معاهد العلم الدوله تتحكم في
المناهج الدوله تتحكم في في المصير في
المجال المتاح امامك للعمل وبالتالي
فهؤلاء هؤلاء علماء يعني هم بشر وهم في في
فتره يعيشون فتره انحطاط لمؤسسه العلماء
ولا لا استبعد ان ان عددا منهم يعني يخضع
للضغوط الحل طبعا انا اريد ان ان اذكر فقط
بحادثه وقعت قبل اسابيع قبل شهور قليله ا
في اثناء الاستفتاء الذي عقدته تركيا على
التعديلات الدستوريه ام ايه طالب بعض
اعضاء الحزب
الحاكم المؤسسه الدينيه التركيه بان ان ان
تدعم ايه ا انصار نعم في الاستفتاء فرفض
رئيس المؤسسه الدينيه رغم انه يعرف انه
الحزب الحاكم هو حزب يعني يحترم الاسلام
ويقدر الاسلام
ويقوده يعني مسلمون خلص وعندما قام احد
العلماء قام احد العلماء في الجانب الاكوي
من اسطنبول ب تحريض المصلين على التصويت
بنعم استدعي هذا العالم للتحقيق من قبل ال
الشؤون الدينيه التركيه اعتقد انه ال ال
المفروض المفروض ان العلماء وهيئات
العلمائي ال الحديثه ان تعلو على السياسه
ان تبتعد عن السياسه وعن تقلبات السياسه
وهذا لمصلحه العلماء هذا لمصلحه الاسلام
وهذا لمصلحه الشعوب لا ينبغي ان يهان
الدين لا ينبغي ان تهان هذه السلطه العليا
في المجتمعات المسلمه وان تصبح مصيه
للحكام وللسلطات اشكرك يا دكتور دكتور
بشير نافع من اوكسفورد المؤرخ المتخصص في
تاريخ الشرق الاوسط كما اشكر من تونس
الدكتور حميده النيفر استاذ الفكر
الاسلامي وبالتاكيد ان هذا موضوع طويل
عريض يحتاج مننا حلقات وحلقات وليس فقط
مجرد ملف هكذا في بهذا الحيز الزمني شكرا
لمتابعتكم مشاهدينا الكرام نهايه الحصاد
الى اللقاء بحول
الله
[موسيقى]
ان